oui ça arrive c'est un mur alors il a
pris c'est parce qu'il aille à rien on
est heureux alors est ce que tu peux
limiter ce qui limite est content de ce
que vous dites mais je vais pas dire
mais il faut que tu le fasses zone à 10
euros avec un invité chez moi des
congolais c'est génial
ah ouais je ne sais pas vous aimez un
don à ce point des divergences et où
l'hiver on était à 2 % de part de marché
vous avez vu l'état des hôpitaux
ces limitations que c est ce que vous
savez imiter ce jeune homme alors vous
allez faire aucune nomination si c'est
si chaque partie je savais faire jacques
chirac allez-y bonjour mais non mais
sérieux c'était absolument épouvantable
au zénith est quelqu'un qui n'est ni de
jacques chirac
vous savez je suis devant françois
mitterrand et vous imitez qui voit tout
le monde aller n'importe qui françois
hollande
vous parlez de ces limitations sarkozy a
là c'est un désastre c'est quand je le
savais je sais je sais il faut jamais
demandé aux chroniqueurs parce qu'on le
sait puisque cyril à c'est moi qui le
fait se plaint de nous et que pour
angers
quand je suis là je vous demande c'est
une erreur une erreur on va s'intéresser
et en a que j'ai très bien imités c'est
qui mon cul bien placé c'est vrai qu'il
devait passer